know what woke is it's a form of
cultural Marxism it's about putting
Merit and achievement behind identity
politics and it's basically a war on the
truth and is that as an infected
institutions it has corrupted a lot of
Institutions so you've got to be willing
to fight the woke we've done it in
Florida cultural Marxism is a far-right
anti-semitic conspiracy theory that
blames Jewish German academics known as
the Frankfurt School for spreading
movements like identity politics and
political correctness as some kind of
way to manipulate and undermine western
civilization and Christian values that's
what cultural Marxism is it also
it uses the word Marxism
so it makes it sound like it's somehow
related to Marx but it's not it's a
misnomer it has nothing to do with the
economic and class analysis of Karl Marx
cultural Marxism is like a post-factual
dog whistle appealing to anti-Semitism
and paranoia that's how that's how
DeSantis is defining woke